they've also issued today an image of a
dark-coloured audi this dark grey audi
which was part of the incident that took
place here on monday night it's believed
that this is the vehicle that joseph
knee was taken away from the scene in
they took him to his associates took him
to to hospital rather than helping
olivia the vehicle and joseph knee were
both left at the hospital the vehicle
recovered from there and police now were
issuing images of that vehicle in order
to jog people's memories to ask them
where they saw it in the build-up to
this attack the attack took place 10 30
on monday night they want people who may
have seen this vehicle either before or
after the attack at any time on monday
evening to let them know exactly where
they saw it and that will enable them to
piece together the movements of this
vehicle potentially the movements of the
people who were involved in this
incident so fresh information coming
from police a fresh appeal for
information meanwhile they continue to
question a 36 year old man arrested by
armed officers last night on suspicion
of causing olivia's death